Check out this week's must see movies!
I chose this life.
And some day it's going to get me killed.
Charlize Theron stars in Atomic Blonde as an undercover agent,
who goes to Berlin on a deadly mission during the cold war.
God, I think I love you.
Welcome to the world inside your phone.
In The Emoji Movie family fun awaits as a specially gifted emoji seeks to become a normal emoji.
Maybe I'm meant to have more than just one emotion.
Storms get stronger and more destructive. This is global warming.
Al Gore returns in An Inconvenient Sequel,
a documentary that revisits the issue of climate change worldwide.
This is our home.
See what's hot in theaters with this week fanticipation.
So, what's your weekend ticket going to be? Let us know by commenting. See you next time on weekend ticket.